you got a billion [ __ ] stories out  there you don't feel motivated that you  need to tell a story today or create go  let somebody else do it if i were you  and i had an hour right now go in the  [ __ ] park right now go back to your  basketball route stand outside the  garden right there and be like what do  you think about the knicks upcoming  season yeah interview four people you  see where i'm going people aren't  starting so you can't create distribute  got it you can't create today facilitate  it there's no excuse for not talking to  the world it just doesn't have to be  your thoughts and words every time my  friends the key to content success is  you've got to start documenting instead  of creating let me tell you how